Oh ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
special effect When you first learn, you are sobbing with ashes on the floor,
praying and overflowing with water 5
more and dreaming
It brings a feeling of disaster like dancing pants
[Music]
4 My name is  I am Jung Kyung-ho. I am
currently
active as a human cultural asset,
and I am currently
serving as the head of
Taekkyeon One researcher in Ciri, Chungju
.  I am in charge of
[Music]
Attack Marriage,
Three Kingdoms Period,
Goguryeo Period, and from now on,
2000 years ago, from the Gogue Period, a
tradition with a sad year of
history
.
Because the rigidity of the right story
is divided into these three stages, with
that basic technique, we were actually attacked by staining and swapping with the other party
5 times, and
doing 5 at night,
we do what we can do before the real
thing.
When the
training
is completed, it becomes a net for real-world practice by applying kicking techniques and fruit distance techniques with the opponent, and it will
calm the mind so that it can change the people
or self-control.
That temperance to do it will nurture strength.
Confidence, each sword, and dignity
are now nurtured, isn't that the essence of
it, of
course, Jackie's awakened little Aira
Tamu, the
ultimate goal is to raise the quality of people
, but this kid is the ultimate
I'll say I have a purpose
[Music]